youpi on n'entendait pas bien lu lé
peuple d'internet aujourd'hui je vous
parle d'un jeu qui s'appelle codename
qui a édité chez iello aussi je sais que
j'ai présentées sur ce calendrier de la
vente deux ou trois jeux de chez iello
alors toujours pas placement produit il
y en a aucun sur toutes ses dents quatre
vidéos par contre cielo y lisons débat
d'idées de jeu à chaque fois donc c'est
pour ça qu'on l'a retrouvé plusieurs
fois
codename c'est un jeu dans l'univers un
peu deux agents troubles
ça se peut par contre qu'ils ont fait
mais je vous en avais parlé c'est un
truc d'agents secrets ou en fait on va
fonctionner par équipe et on doit faire
deviner des noms d'agents à l'autre
équipe je sais pas si vous avez regardé
la série bureau des légendes avait lieu
sur canal
mais c'est un peu dans cet état d'esprit
du mois le côté on doit faire deviner
des noms de code je vous fais avoir ici
c'est beaucoup plus simple à comprendre
en fait il ya des cartes rouges et bleus
et des neutrons donc ce sont des
personnages lambda ou des vrais
personnages de votre équipe ou de
l'équipe adverse et des mots la manière
de faire deviner ses mots à l'autre
équipe c'est de passer par de
l'association l'idée par exemple le lie
à champagne en pyramide licorne neige
bretelles papier pour champagne
je vais peut-être dire simplement
bouteille 1
ça veut dire qu'il ya une carte sur tout
le plateau en rapport avec le mot
bouteille et c'est celle ci qui va
trouver donc là c'est facile ça fait ch
en pagne et c'est comme ça que la
personne va pouvoir retourner mais
attention il faut pas qu'il retourne
l'écart de l'autre équipe et il faut pas
qu'ils se fassent des masses 40 en
question ces règles là c'est un peu
confuse à expliquer si vous n'êtes pas
le jeu dans les mains mais je pense que
vous commencez à comprendre l'essence
même du jeu
le seul problème que pouvait générer
potentiellement ce jeu et
ou alors les deux problème c'est que
comment est ce qu'on fait pour y jouer à
deux parce que c'est clairement un jeu
d'équipé et le deuxième souci c'est
comment on remet la disposition parce
que la disposition elle doit être
précise pour que les personnes qu'ils
fassent deviner sache où sont les cartes
à faire deviner lesquels sont bleues et
rouges états et donc il faut un
positionnement spécial là ils ont une
bonne idée
une riche idée même dirais-je ils ont
pris mes 40 cartes clés les cartes clés
ou à peu près ce visage là et c'est un
placement bas qui va être aléatoire
parce qu'on va pas retenir les 40 comme
ça ça servirait à rien et donc on pioche
ça au départ et en place les cartes en
fonction pour le côté impossible de
jouer à deux ils ont créé des règles à
deux joueurs et ça j'apprécie beaucoup
en fait on les jeux peuvent se jouer à
deux donc ils ont reformulé un peu les
règles pour y jouer à deux c'est
possible c'est drôle c'est vraiment très
sympa parce qu'un petit défi de l'esprit
par contre il faut que les deux joueurs
soient vraiment faire dans leur manière
de jouer parce que c'est très facile de
faire battre l'autre le but quand on
joue à deux c'est vraiment d'arriver à
le faire c'est jouer pour jouer en fait
tout simplement
voilà ça s'appelle codename j'ai pas
grand chose à dire de plus sur ce jeu si
ce n'est qu'il est très sympa il se joue
bien les règles sont faciles à apprendre
et que vous avez un lien dans la
description à côté du lien des places du
spectacle pour l'olympia n'oubliez pas
d'indiquer la vidéo c'est ça vous a plu
rendez vous demain à 6 heures du matin
abonnez vous ciao bye au revoir à sa
liste à son arrivée
[Musique]
oh